Mr Trump's plane has landed in Columbus
in Georgia that's of course ahead of him
addressing Republicans at a conference
in the city there you go if we just
listen
they were just um cheering him just then
I just heard as the plane touched down
those are Republican supporters at the
side of the runway there cheering as he
lands I can see a couple of them Maga
hats as well of course standing for make
America great again
there are apparently a lot of people
also awaiting him at that Convention
Center for him to arrive in fact
according to our correspondent Mark
Stone the tickets for that went up since
his indictment here he is
Donald's Trump stepping down from the
Trump Lane in Columbus Georgia
we're seeing the former U.S president
for the first time since the indictment
was unsealed
the special counsel for the Department
of Justice
taking us through the indictments
including an indictment under the
Espionage Act
[Music]
let's listen in
[Applause]
all right we can hear them chanting USA
Donald Trump backing and waving
[Applause]
wearing his trademark long red tie
waving to people with supporters
Donald Trump has just landed in Columbus
Georgia where he is due to speak to the
state party convention he's speaking not
once but twice
[Music]